I might need some help with this now you
guys we're in California you guys know
there are California slugs you know the
California Raisins right yeah these are
California slugs now this one right here
let's just take a look that's a pretty
good-looking slug right there right look
at the size of that slug it is that's a
brownie here no no not really getting
close no no no no no all right hold on
to your butts okay watch this this is
the largest slug species in the world
and I have brought one for each and
every one of you look at that that is a
black see her go ahead it's not gonna
bite you just put your hands out real
gentle like that get out of this okay do
you wanna you don't have to do this this
dr. Malcolm come on don't worry we
actually say the largest one for you my
friend grey there it is that's Bernie
these slugs are fantastic they're
gastropods to live we're off the coast
here in California you guys probably out
there surfing don't even realize that
these are all over the place out there
they do not bite they do not sting they
are completely safe and how slimy is
that right SGO so how do they reproduce
oh that's very interesting cunning they
actually create what's called a daisy
chain so they have 30 or 40 slugs lined
up you never know which one's a male
which ones a female you can't just go
out into the park and lift up the slug
skirts so they can change their sexes
male and female at the same time so 30
of them hook up at a time they don't
know who's male who's female just
whoever's in the front is the female and
then you line up one after another you
know you can actually use this slime as
hair gel okay
no I think no okay all right well you've
creeped everyone out
you